yeah and there's still a lot of
companies that we sell to that you know
you put up a a screenshot of a a user's
profile on tongle and they go oh wait a
second that's got all my stuff on it
right I had that reaction when I did a
demo of tongle at one of our our
conferences in May and so I've started
doing my demos now logged out of tungle
and I I eventually log in right but um
so there's still a lot of companies that
are real paranoid about where is this
data going um especially remote devices
blackberries and iPhones and that and
it's an interesting issue because if I
am in a company that you know decides
one day I don't need you know I'm not
needed anymore and they go do a remote
wipe my personal data is probably on
that device too and I just I had no shot
to get to it right so there's all sorts
of interesting implications of who owns
my data in email I get that right in
email yeah okay fine I left the company
you want your email back no problem but
the calendar the calendar is kind of
like me right that's me as an individual
so there's definitely some issues that
haven't really been worked through yet
and that people are going to struggle
with and how do you think it's going to
evolve I think that um I think having
aggregation points I think having redund
data I mean you know that's great they
can wipe my Blackberry but it's it's on
tongle right now so I know that I've got
a copy there I just hope that nobody
goes and sinks in overwrites it
tomorrow but um I think redundant data I
think overlays you know publishing
through caldav and things like that some
of which we have to catch up on
admittedly you know give people some
ability to own their own data around
their own self and overlay that and
marry it with their professional
environment um but I think that Line's
very very blurry and I don't expect
we're going to move to any point of
clarity I think the natur nature of work
has changed so much that trying to keep
your work life and your personal life
completely separate and secure from each
other in 2015 we won't even think about
that concept interesting and so if you
look at um you know back when it was
client server you've had you know your
company had your your data on their
server and and then then it start to
migrate towards the web right what were
some of the privacy concerns back when
it started actually there it's still now
it's still there yeah yeah but but okay
so so what were the challenges and some
of them have already been brought down
like if you look at Salesforce I think
you know Salesforce has done a good job
in educating people that the cloud is is
is safe right yeah I mean we're we're at
a point where not every everybody's
bought in right we did a survey with um
one of our resellers 600 people filled
it out in the last few weeks more than
half the participants in the survey said
we'll never do anything in the
cloud you know yeah it's 2010 right so
are those banks are those government
agencies are those insurance companies
are they manufacturing you know I don't
I haven't gone and looked at that data
yet but half of them just said no no
Cloud period but the other half were
like oh yeah Cloud's an inflection point
great opportunity for us we want to do
more and it's the pervasive access it's
the fixed cost of operation I mean
there's all the all those benefits so I
think there are still many many issues
that companies need to get their heads
around of okay my data is going to live
somewhere else and that's okay but what
data is it that's going to be okay if it
lives out there um we look at in in the
email world in the archiving space right
there is the traditional on premise you
know heavyduty IBM common store kind of
content management stuff that is really
secure and really well managed and then
there's in the cloud archiving providers
like aonian who are just treating it
like any other data feed that's going to
go live on an Amazon server and with the
right passwords and other authentication
you're going to get to it so it's a risk
factor thing and a lot of companies that
are you know risk adverse are not going
to go there a lot of companies that say
the trade-offs are worth it like many uh
decisions about sort of web 2o in
general right now are going to say this
is okay for us we know the risks you
know the users in control or we as as an
entity are still in control enough that
this is okay but you still find plenty
of people that in 2010 aren't ready to
be on Facebook aren't ready to be on
LinkedIn aren't ready to be on Twitter
those are the kind of people that
probably are still not ready to have
their corporate data living out in the
club on the other hand there is
Salesforce there is Google Apps there is
lotus live um you know and companies are
hungry for that kind of you know SAS
business model and are willing to accept
the risk to get the the benefit of
predictable service always upgrading uh
fixed cost and you know sort of all the
other benefits so I think privacy is a
concern but I think there's a lot of
other pieces to The Mex you know um and
then I think the other question that
really has to be answered is how much
sharing do I end up doing I think in
most companies still people don't make
their calendar wide open they don't let
people see what they're working on and
there has to be a way to make that
socially acceptable in the company just
like it has been to share my documents
and share my knowledge right CU I mean
we've gone down this curve in in
collaboration in general when we started
shipping nodes 20 years ago we had to
teach companies why it would be good to
share the information that everybody had
in the company most companies were my
knowledge is my value to the company and
so our first notes customers actually
had to put incentive programs in place
for humans to get compensated for
putting stuff into notes
databases it's kind of the same with
calendars I still don't really feel
comfortable telling people what am I
spending my time on every day my own
staff though probably could really
benefit from seeing which customers I'm
meeting or what projects I'm spent
choosing to spend my time on what are my
priorities more then at a once a month
staff meeting or whatever so there's
still a cultural barrier and I see that
in lots of our customers and I think it
just stems from the personal nature of
caliber